are you ready David are you ready Donald
go get the censor bars on else knows
yes cover up that monstrosity how did I
ever get on 80s TV it's disgusting
what's that thing you have to pee holes
that's just not right it's simply it's
not right through fucking them
government anywhere we have a we have a
winner I'm the cheater you cheated on oh
hang your bag in shame you worthless
sack of life well I guess that means you
win David by default
nicely done get that back on we are fair
here at our hostage situation thing this
is pop quiz hotshot fair version I'm the
Nostalgia Critic and ever since I was a
child I always want to play games
quoting movies and TV with my friends
the only problem was I had no friends
well now that I have power I can take my
friends by force with the help of my new
pal general anaesthetic
I can kidnap all the friends I want and
force them to answer questions it might
say by the Bell style sent there will be
laughs trivia those disturbing cartoons
that give you night terrors but most of
all there will be fun the laughter and
joy will last however long I want
heads up America or this is pop quiz
hotshot
[Music]
and on bag of general anesthetic there
we go
welcome to pop quiz hotshot or is the
kids like to call it we are here to play
our game but before we do we want to
find out about these two lovely hostages
David it says here you want to work for
Pixar yes I do I graduated over a year
ago and I'm working on my portfolio I
want to be either a concept artist or a
3d modeler can you get them to stop
making car sequels cuz that would be
amazing I will do my best and and get
Incredibles to going faster I know
they're making it but come on give me
more Brad Bird come on
have general anaesthetic with a gun can
always make backup all right oh I don't
kill you Donald
it says here that you like heavy metal
music and bad horror movies
oh yeah totally I mean they kind of go
hand in hand you know the bad stuff with
the awesome you know metal music it
works out great especially when you have
Slayer going to troll 2 or something
like that dude it's like it works out I
would like to point out that they were a
match made in heaven in Maximum
Overdrive
ok oh yeah you see they seen that movie
oh yeah
yeah without a CDC dude yeah I mean it's
just Willy oh Estevez entrons Maximum
Overdrive
and if it was done with Backstreet Boys
be extreme overdrive cuz everything the
90's was extreme or as Alf likes to say
that would be an awesome badge yes yes
but we do not play this game unless we
know how to play this game general
anesthetic fill us in each contestant is
asked a series of questions involving
the sounds of quotes
if the contestant does not know the
answer but can make the nostalgia critic
laugh ten points are still given but
look out for the spasms the first one to
hit their buzzer when they appear ends
the round while the other has to pay the
penalty through round two where the
quotes get even harder the winner with
the most points face off against the
nostalgia critic and a one-on-one match
if the contestant wins they walk out
with a cash prize and also their lives
if they lose the cash prize will be
added to the next contestants winning
you already said that we're gonna start
with a round one here Donald in
Ghostbusters - what does Peter Venkman
wonder out loud when the Ghostbusters
arrived at the Statue of Liberty who
doll gorillas I had a duck I could have
been a contender I've heard some weird
answers my friend what the fuck with
that surprisingly no it's whether she's
naked under her tracks she is I want
David which Kubrick movie contains the
line there's not one horse in Vietnam
there's something basically wrong with
I'm going to say Gone with the Wind
Stanley Kubrick's go on with the war in
Vietnam definitely I'll give you ten
point because I'm just hoping those go
to better Easter USS Donald which lime
from Jerry Maguire was used by the Joker
in the Dark Knight you had me at hello
good yes you completely oh and that's
also Danson Davis in the matrix which
character was the Oracle referring to
when she said to neo I can see why she
likes you Ada Wong it's like the only
woman outside of the article in the
movie and shear her name as if you could
forget at all he's clearly Trinity
Donald which Mike Myers movie contains
the line no stairway denied Wayne world
yes David which late-night talk show
tagline was spoken by Jack Torrance in
the shining I can't believe it's not
butter
there are so many questions I have with
that one why would Jack Nicholson say
that to what late-night show would say
that was Ed McMahon just like an years I
can't believe it's not butter why would
he say that nobody would say that except
Chevy Chase show that was pretty bad no
it was here's me Johnny
can't believe it's not butter virility
Gone with the Wind and that line but no
that was not true Donald a really tricky
one complete this classic TV opening
line live from New York it's Saturday
night
yes David in Conan the Barbarian who is
Conan speaking to when he says grant me
revenge and if you do not listen that
you Hetal you I'm gonna have to say Gary
Busey's teeth general where did you get
these - these are strange strange
strange people and again you remember
the last episode be sewer stranger how
did you do that where do you you know I
don't want to know don't tell me don't
tell me where you're from don't tell me
how you were conceived I want to know
nothing about your existence except who
created you which clearly is crumb its
crumb damage our one true God with the
hilarious name who prays to trump or as
Ben's Isis comb Donald
which often repeated sentence was
mentioned in all six Star Wars movies
we're in the forest be with you good yes
it was actually I've got a bad feeling
about this I also have detective Davis
which movie featured the Nicolas Cage
line you know I can eat a peach for Alex
the bucket list
watch it else help me
that was funnier than you else is
funnier than you right now man watch it
no no that's Jack Nicholson Morgan
Freeman I don't even know why I know
that but you forced me to think of them
that terrible movie and that's why I'm
so angry at you right now you pulled
that 20 points what the hell I'm sorry
that's a very bad thing this is the easy
route these are the easy questions up it
up face off don't really face off that
whale give want you a point of getting a
dog baby later though Donald which Mel
Brooks movie contains the repeated line
it's good to be the king producers know
is actually history of the world part
ones good guess though David which two
characters had the following dialogue in
Superman
- I'll meal before you if it will save
lives
it will starting with your own Superman
inside clothes Zod and the president
hopefully Superman will be president why
don't I just castrate those things
it looks like Donald has avoided this
fast attack nicely done and that of
course means David you must pay the
penalty as a penalty of my choosing I'm
getting a Power Ranger vibe from you you
like Power Rangers oh yes you watch it
yeah you remember said the big cool guy
with like you know the long spear any of
the cool Darth Vader mask and the cool
boys you get to be Rita so while we get
him in the Rita wardrobe we are going to
show Donald the spazzy cartoon I would
give Max and Mikey oh you like that cuz
you're the horror movie fan and like
some ac/dc over that or it's a white
zombie I like this I'm gonna give you
ten extra points for that I'm actually
not Oh still because how can you compare
to this David as Rita God you look so
Japanese it's amazing really pretty yeah
you just put the head on all the Sun
you're just like you're either a
character from Power Rangers or a
Pokemon and both are equally terrifying
elf what do you think I think I'm
getting my
Filip humor from you okay we now go into
round two where the questions get even
harder god help you both and we are
gonna start with Donald which film had
two line it's been six weeks since the
down Hussein was killed by wild boars
and the world is still glad to be rid of
him The Human Centipede good guess it
wouldn't be shocked if this was in there
was actually sell far bigger Longer &
uncut that's one of those were I read
the question I did look at the answer
yet I'm like what movie is this so I got
to see that movie again enter cop to it
David made the Stallone film that had
this line where police officers we're
not trained to handle this kind of
violence yes
whatever you know repulses favorite
movies I'm sure I love Wesley Snipes
hair Donald in the Shawshank Redemption
which actors said get busy living or get
busy dying Tim Robbins yes David
named the alien movie with the following
line they're coming out of the goddamn
walls if you added an S you are off by
an ass oh you little a - where's the
Rita always had a you know the mouth
never matched up so maybe the S was
delayed as well no it was aliens Donald
in which film did Tom Cruise shout red
light green light Tropic Thunder it was
actually Mission Impossible and without
Days of Thunder
David complete this line from Robin Hood
men in tights a fight to the death
mano-a-mano man to man just you me and
Dupree it's just the fact that you said
it has a question like he's just so
determined you me and you breathe yeah I
give him the point
I appreciate what little everyone do
that Donald in Star Trek - to whom was
Khan speaking when he said I shall leave
you as you left me marooned for all
eternity in the center of a dead planet
if you don't get this one I will kill
you
Captain Kirk yes it's like - Ted three
characters people remember from that
movie and only two
a rivalry so obviously one of those two
David finish this line from Monty Python
and the Holy Grail now go away or I
shall see II know you make me sad so be
it Donald finish this live from The
Princess Bride
life is paying highness anyone who tells
you different is you've broken my camera
[Music]
what am I supposed to say to that I mean
it's like you can say anything that
English language is at your disposal
and you give me that how am I supposed
to react what am I supposed to do with
that I don't know man you're the one the
kidnapped us you know what that's true
there's only one response to that and
it's see you got a date with alpha now
in there give them back he's my back elf
you're suddenly funny again
David finish this live from Blazing
Saddles no no don't do that don't do
that if you shoot him you'll just
explode he's just so excited like you're
actually even more excited than Rita in
it's like Rita without the hate it's
like she could be a light motivator if
any was dealing down just like can I get
your life back together will explode
together
guys I love it give him the points by
the way the line is make him man which
you do not for me sir Donald finish this
line from Blade Runner all those
movements will be lost in time like
tears in rain time to get a job well
kind of clothes die which many would say
is close to getting a job but I'll give
you the place for that that was the
twist the whole thing was just a
metaphor for Harrison Ford getting a job
or not
Chara is tricky now listen Star Wars
David what David Fincher film ended with
the line you've met me at a very strange
time in my life
The Curious Case of Benjamin Button no
but Rita Repulsa - seen that really oh
yeah definitely one of my favorites
really Rita gave him the police you
should be very proud
Donald what Matt Damon film had the line
sometimes I wish I had never met you
because then I could go to sleep at
night not knowing there was someone like
you out there Bourne Identity no it's
like the one movie everyone knows him
from what's like before Bourne Identity
what's the one movie you knew him from
yes why would he say that if Bourne
Identity he cheats Emily two words in
foreign identity and so does wife and it
was removable he's no but that said that
is the ending sound which means that
David you have sixty points Donald you
have fifty it was the reader what the
Rita hold it together well done my
friend
I'm almost debating having you wear that
in the final round but yeah no I am
Donald Mayer well let's do if that's
even a word it probably is it's a word I
made up but what not be made up it's
your death yes take care of my friend
take care be sure to shoot him yes yes
that's the spot there you go you fucking
cheater we will be right back with the
final round of pop quiz hotshot stay
tuned
[Music]
if you would like to be a contestant a
pop quiz hotshot and live in the
Chicagoland area send a video via
YouTube stating your name a and why you
think it would be a good contestant
[Music]
and welcome back to pop quiz on shot
David congratulations you'll be battling
against a nostalgia critic on our final
round I'll be reading off seven
questions whoever answers the most
correctly will win this the holy grail
paper clip holder for the person who has
everything and clearly doesn't need it
also $100 in cash and of course you're
live beautiful alright I'll be reading
off back to the future quotes you'll
have to match the quotes with the movie
David are you ready ready
Kemosabe are you ready just read right
here we go David party who trusts you
like that you did doc thank you teacher
- incorrect critic it's leave you idiot
make like a tree and leave you sound
like a damn fool you say it wrong
thanks and future - correct David better
get used to these bars kid back to the
future - incorrect critic roads or going
we won't need roads back to the future
correct
David I guess you guys aren't ready for
that yet but your kids are gonna love it
back to the future correct critic shark
still looks fake back to future -
correct David your future is whatever
you make so I'm gonna get a good one
both of you back to the future -
incorrect critic your father is in the
same place he's been for the past 12
years
Oh Park Cemetery back to future -
correct
David I'm George George McFly I'm your
density I mean
back to the future correct critic oh
I've heard some whoppers in my day but
the fact that you expect me to entertain
a motion like that is so insulting back
to Future 3 correct David oh I know you
did see me back in the future but I'm
back I'm back from the future back to
the future to correct critic
listen obvious would I am to shoot
somebody today and I prefer to be you
correct Damon you're too much like your
old man
no McFly has there amounted to anything
in the history of Hill Valley back to
the future - incorrect and critic no
wonder the circuits failed it says Made
in Japan incorrect and the winner is alt
says indeed II and that's what I'm gonna
do while you check out the cemetery so
have fun my friend don't forget to
return the hat I hope you had fun today
you get to wear the crown wow that put
that back on we're too mean here I'll
see you next time on pop quiz hotshot
not they're different watch out yes he
watches you I would doubt it
do you think there's intelligent life
out there yes and I've shot them all wow
really
oh yes you didn't report it or anything
no did they look like him at all
a few of them did more of them look like
Bert and Ernie but that's about it
they also had very phallic noses the
more that is true they yeah Vernell saw
the Pelican oh yeah a guy never even
thought about that that's that's quite
disturbing and look we got blood do they
believe purple purple blood Wow like
does it come when they get excited does
anything come out of like their schnoz
or their keyholders yeah Bailey through
their nipples but over the matter what
color is fat
their nipples are actually a very very
light Jewish of boom no kidding it's
only one thing to say that
[Music]
let's go